a quasi government agency known as the
men in black
while this Peter Graves hosted
conspiracy program is a fun way to
unload some exposition it's still a
bunch of narration and exposition nair
funds position here is one of their
stories that never happened
Pete uses the scissoring method of
finger quoting instead of the more
acceptable Farley rabbit ears method of
fingering them and now I'm in the mood
to watch the movie bound and I have no
idea why from one of their files that
doesn't exist would you file it under
the letter X someone should make a super
great show for about five seasons and
then disappoint everyone you know like
every show ever the zarthans princess
lauranna beseeched the men in black to
hide the light from Serleena jeez beary
why even make the movie if you're just
gonna lay the full story force
little-known facts on a foul this German
foretell don't show the men in black
subdued Cervino
allowing the south arms to escape
Serleena released from her captors made
a minute I know this so-called history
show is cheaply produced but how did
Serleena
get released from her captors I guess
it's saying that once the zarthans
escaped the men in black were distracted
by all the beautiful women leaving the
planet but this program really yada-yada
at how Selena got free you mean the
movie is set exactly at the time that it
came out this is fun and all for people
who came to see it when it was released
but what about now in 2019 I Spit on
your movie release time setting
congruence if you have the intelligence
and engineering to traverse light-years
of space I'm going to go ahead and say
that you should also have the
intelligence and engineering to figure
out things like reverse propulsion and
landing gear not sure do the crash
landing thing for reasons cute trick and
all but doesn't this make the
proportions of the opening planet
destruction montage a little wacky I
mean coming around this planet with
rings which only exists on gas giants by
the way it looks to be the size of a
decent moon and even if you are dealing
with ridiculous force perspective the
weapons its deploying appear to contact
a huge area also when the ship landed it
kicked up a small mound of dirt in front
of it but now just sitting on flat land
don't lie to me about your size and then
tell me it was just a joke Roger waiting
for hunt Jesus how much more amazing
with this movie a bin if this alien had
turned itself into Larry David hardy-har
the creature bases its form on a
Victoria's Secret at accept how would it
understand relative size and depth based
on this layout you can barely even tell
she has two legs in this shot if this
were real the creature would have ended
up being a one
one legged creature with only a left
hand and no foot that drives itself
along the ground by nubs in other words
a better movie also hasn't hot medusa
already seen humans that is if we're
supposed to believe Peter Graves who
just so happens to be right about
basically everything else including the
exact design of its ship were humans at
that meeting hey pretty lady this
walking sexual assault stereotype is
either completely ignoring that this
woman's face just came from Chompy Venus
flytrap snakes or he just accidentally
accosted her not even sure which is less
realistic or disgusting
this Bush alone saved them millions on
special effects but why exactly did she
go back there - if I'm reading the movie
correctly vomit up boots and a jacket
she can make clothes out of her sneaky
powers also and I don't even like saying
this but it's hard to read this as
anything but a sick eating disorder joke
this entire intro to this character is
all kinds of X and all kinds of ist's
and I can't believe it happened in the -
Caze hey Steve did you finish all the
visual effects on that scene or Cronk
strangles the flower creature if I say
yes can we go grab some in-n-out sure
I'd love a double-double animal style
then yes all visual effects have been
completed how the good age of t even get
into the men in black being this stupid
last movie showed us that even the best
of the best have a difficult time
getting in J survives this isn't the
whole point of the MIB to keep us
regular folks from knowing there are
aliens just gonna go ahead and add 10
sins for all the times in this movie
that would have been impossible also
it's impossible that Jeff the 600-foot
worm is a regular inhabitant of New York
City subways and nobody has seen it this
movie makes it seem like there aren't
gobs of people who work on the track
homeless people and Peter Parker finding
out the truth about his dad that
wouldn't have seen Jeff and the secret
would be out why is there nobody on the
platform later when J is talking to the
MIB headquarters it is shown to be a
busy station with tons of riders now
maybe they wouldn't need a good
neuralyzer because they didn't see the
600-foot work they definitely have
questions the irony of the green screen
reflection is that it could easily have
been replaced with some black CGI paint
or some watches step you will have a
nice evening J game all the passengers
of story as is protocol but captain
Larry sat in the driver's seat the
entire time and did not get a story he
was an asshole but he deserves a story
sigh fella stationed close well good
thing J told these two people about it
but nobody put up a barrier of any sort
not to mention all the people who are
currently running around the station
already what's better than Johnny
Knoxville - Johnny Knoxville's you ever
heard of James Edwards play saved the
lives of about 85 people on the subway
85 I'll give you 20 mr. hyperbolized
sure people won't know what this flashy
thing is but why does he need to do this
in a king diner excuse me uh but he's
kind of shy but he thinks you are hot
relationships are easy though
considering he basically just turned him
into the human equivalent of a potato
I'm sure he'll be putty in her hands
you're too late
tomorrow at midnight the line
we'll leave the third planet and be back
home sounds like a she's actually not
too late and B you told her this for no
goddamn reason other than to advance the
fly can hate people who are close to
death in movies they are very talky
third Rock from the Sun I never got that
don't discount Zaphod Beeblebrox
apparently has a custom beaded jacket
made for his extra noggin can someone
please explain to me how the head works
with that sleeve and even with a zipper
you need a second person to unzip and
zip it the practicality of it all is
well worth of sin so is that just
something the agents can do shouldn't
there be a ruling body or organizational
structure that decides on when these
kinds of things happen that be my fault
sir I'm very sorry sir please don't no
lies me sir
what if somebody decides you won't um
always be there baby would you want to
forget that there was a killing earlier
once ever some spring alien on alien I'm
fascinated to know how the men in black
managed these cases because you know the
cops were called and they told people
back at the station about it so did the
MIB send out people specifically to
investigate the chain of command at a
police station so they know who to
narrow eyes you can't count Elle
I mean she wanted to go back to the
morgue there are many rumors as to why
Linda Fiorentino didn't come back for
men in black too but there is no way her
character wanted to go back to the
morgue oh yeah
from outer space I just remember when
talking dogs were the very definition of
hilarious I hope so because this movie
is approximately 57% chatty canine humor
King Frank a light they just kept asking
been about a life why couldn't she tell
him this back at the pizza place again
why is this diner the best place to
knurl eyes people good god man I'll see
you what you all see me that's family
why would she say this it's lonely
because the people he interrogate suono
who he is the only reason why she's
saying this is because she's rosario
dawson and she's the romantic interest
I'll flash you some other time yet
another reason why the MIB couldn't
possibly prevent the knowledge of aliens
from the general population Boehner's an
agent jay is horrible at his job
guessing it's for plot reasons
am i close well that was Laura she
should be here but she is very not that
kids know
based on his threat Frank is either
castrating or impregnating this man now
and I'm not actually sure what a movie
is anymore
I gave the order my best states have
carried it out well let's ask the agent
can dead thrown up it works at the post
office was it hard to just say agent K
or Tommy Lee Jones either one would work
it's not like the people who are
watching this movie don't know it's him
there's no reason for the guessing game
yes very existence may rest on white K
knows because we weighed the options of
either not having Tommy Lee Jones in
this and honoring the integrity of the
first movies conclusion versus the pile
of money we would make by being able to
put you both on the poster again and
you'll never guess what one in what town
did the retired white folk gather to
hear a postmaster speak about proper
packaged techniques you are a former
agent of a top secret organization and
monitors extraterrestrials on earth I
feel like it would be easier to just
neuralyzed k again give him the story
that he used to be in the MIB and get
him out of there before trying to
convince him like this I mean wouldn't
that work stamps Oh
luckily for J this small-town post
office just happens to have biz markie
the alien working for it multiple aliens
working for it I mean where they put
here just in case J needed to prove
aliens exist this is a small town in
Massachusetts how does the MIB account
for all these assholes outside of New
York just about everybody works in a
post office as an alien I guess that
also means everyone at the DMV Congress
any place where there are potential
weirdos let's move e up the alien
population on earth by eight hundred
percent from the last one there's
absolutely nothing I can say here that
would be funny appropriate or not
misconstrued in some way so it's just
acknowledged this cameo was problematic
even in 2002 and move on shall we get
him armed enough to speed and over to
Dean you realization in that order maybe
get Kay's mind back before handing over
weapons and top-secret info the most
advanced technologies from all over the
universe are in this room props
Department was like how do we convey
advanced technology oh I know everything
is Chrome hands in your pockets or and
I'm just spitballing here maybe don't
leave an entire civilization completely
unprotected in the middle of a crowded
storage room the dinner Eliza my
question is why does that make a big
deal out of telling Jay it's too bad
you're wiped out this entire memory of
it when there's a D neuralyzer
Cylon ongoing Serleena is about to tak
the MIB headquarters so why does she
bother with the Immigration and
Naturalization nonsense
is it the overindulgent product
placement
because I think it might be the
overindulgent product placement in the
background really want to learn how to
be an underwear model they told me I've
got real potential this is why the human
body should be normalized instead of
objectified titties shouldn't trigger
hypoxic blackouts the D neuralyzer room
has an escape hatch system that
literally flushes people because the
people who run the men in black have an
incredible sense of humor about security
breaches but my question is does
anywhere else in the building of a
system like this because the D
neuralyzer can't be a place where people
go very often it's amazing they have the
funds to include one in such a low
traffic area fresh out can help you it's
unbelievable this guy is stalling these
guys and this movie by claiming he
doesn't have a D neuralyzer
especially when J found out he was
selling one through King eBay so why is
this happening
still working off the 6.0 bad news monk
gear up by 5.07 softwares so quit trying
to pad your stats bro hate the extended
cut up to bite people
why reshoot on a new street in front of
a new building on a new side of town
when you can do your way through
filmmaking also the problem with these
convenient alien brain refreshers for
mr. Lee Jones here is that they can be
seen by anyone the idea that the MIB
could keep alien life secret if it were
this prevalent and obvious is the
biggest load of implausible deniability
in the entire franchise all the Orion
constellation he remembers that one
thing about that other movie where it
meant something or other here's the
problem in July 2002 Orion was only
visible if you were standing in
Antarctica that's right we're up here
putting the smart ass and astronomy in
smartest Rana I mean putting the smart
ass in your smart Esther this movie
sucks okay he's a boss idiot also I'm
guessing that's not the name of this
dudes race which I'm guessing makes that
Stephen racist also also what happened
to the two-headed johnny Knoxville guy
he was here just a second ago but when
Kay came to save Jay he beat up or
killed all the other guys and we never
saw him leave or anything is he used to
drive that old busted John Paul II that
John thing existed before creed why
would Tessa Thompson talk like she made
that up that and it's a Pennsylvania
expression pick Pennsylvania
if SEDs being hung upside down here I
guess that means no other place in the
entire MIB headquarters had one of those
escape hatch flushing apparatuses then
huh
dear Groucho God and Moe Howard heaven
what in the is this movie that jeez how
do we reenacting the scenes from the
fugitive now you left yourself clues
yeah in case I had to be demoralized
because my replacement couldn't handle
the situation and that's different than
just having your memories because
seriously either you want the info
erased or not anything else is just an
excuse for the plotting plot to plot and
plot also if this situation was so
important why didn't Kay write down
exact instructions and put it in a safe
that only Zedd would know about anything
other than this Da Vinci Code nonsense
who would stack pizza boxes like this as
someone who worked for a pizza place I
can tell you two things someone was
stoned and this is a fire hazard
also they weren't stacked like this
before so this is a dumb observation for
many reasons there is no way that this
key wasn't discovered over the course of
25 years and wasn't lost or stolen MIB
sequels are like taking my dog to the
vet sentence I'm least hoping to hear is
those strange worm things are back in
both cases I leave severely disappointed
once you go worm that's what you'll
yearn um don't fall asleep politeness
Laura you're in a room of sassy molesty
alien worms don't feel like you have to
smile and give J for leaving her with
the fondle squad I'd like to keep my
enemies confused we all confused k
detective del Spooner would be excellent
at cinema since looks like the Saline
race that worships K built their world
with a lot of New York City trash but
how did they get inside the locker mouth
they might be small enough to fit inside
a locked locker none of the stuff their
city is made of is small enough and we
all know K didn't spend hours building
their city for them you never checked
out a tape discount natalie portman you
reserved one once but you never picked
it up none of K scavenger hunt makes
sense at all too many things could have
gone wrong the key to the locker just
hanging out in the open at the pizza
parlor using a train station Locker in
the first place and leaving something in
a place of business even a business that
will last forever and always like a
movie rental store is a huge risk Chara
it's just a sin that they've kept a
genius like you locked away is it though
hmm
processing processing nope I think it
makes sense that he stayed locked away
notes in there evil sexy plant lady and
if there's one thing we are consistent
about around here
that's not sinning sins that aren't
actually since so that's definitely a
sit there evil Scout Agent J caught me
safely there it's ozone to sell on the
black market
they're very touchy about this global
warming thing not anymore Jarrah we have
accepted that we are totally to plan to
single-use plastics to our doom I'm
sending the human race here wait are
they in the video store anymore
did they go to this dude's house by the
way is it weird that David Cross is
playing a different character in this
movie after the character he played in
the last movie was killed I say it's
weird an M night scare achter from glass
agrees but the zarthans had a great
treasure the light of Zartha
in a movie that can't even get to an
hour and a half and including the
credits if you want to double x position
me with the same crappy VHS tape played
the entire way through both times I'm
not gonna lie movie is starting to make
me actively angry good not to intervene
so wait k went through all this bull to
reserve a tape that didn't even have
accurate information on it with the goal
being to trigger his memory later man he
could have bought the tape and again
gave it to Zed or put it in a safe and
nobody would have figured out anything
even if they were the hugest Peter gray
fans on the planet also earlier we
needed a machine to bring back neural
eyes memories but now a simple video
presentation will do the trick I
remember the days when de-aging an actor
just meant darkening their hair shooting
it at night running it back at 5 frames
per second and lowering the resolution
eat your heart out Marvel third the
second y'all get back from Cambodia move
your bum ass out of your mom's house you
want to go to Cambodia yeah hey mom why
the is he picking up a shovel and asking
for his mom
he's either about to kill her or dick to
Cambodia and I hate that I've confused
about where this movie is leading me
Scrat by the way we haven't seen that
jackass scratch since the D neuralyzer
scene and we won't see him again the
rest of the movie even though he's
supposedly involved at every step it
seems like primary henchman duties
transferred to Jarrah but without any
explanation as to where he went or why
this movie cares not for your need of
character consistency and resolution and
Knight's character for glass does
approve of this barry sonnenfeld cameo
but i overruled his ass and this is a
sin can try to pick off a few things
this family is the thermostat set at a
blistering 84 loss barry sonnenfeld is
wearing long sleeves maybe this is part
of that new hotness Will Smith is always
yammering on about also the code is
simply to go down to 60 back up to 84
and down to 60 again if you were hiding
a super secret stash of alien weaponry
letting you go for something a little
more secure than a regular March we
in Nashville there on what amounts to a
freight elevator and right did they just
jump up here and reach far enough to
press themselves against the ceiling oh
yeah me someone I need to eat how
disappointing is this villain Serleena
can be who she wants to be and is super
powerful but after she takes over the
MIB headquarters she basically does
nothing but wait around and give orders
the story never allows her to shine and
it's far more focused on Ches stupid
scavenger hunt than her character
development the producers of the movie
thought we loved these worm assholes so
much that we not only wanted to see them
again but would love it if they were
brought along for the final fight for no
reason whatsoever the producers of this
movie were wrong
so these fancy shiny alien guns shoot
regular old bullets then is it wrong
that something so gross gives me a boner
is it also wrong that when I saw Tommy
Lee Jones wrapped up in snakes I also
wrap myself up in snakes and put a
picture of Lara Flynn Boyle on a vacuum
cleaner and pretended this was happening
to me I have to say the best part of
this launch room are the five flashing
neon green arrows sections with the
English word up underneath very helpful
I wanted in pieces why didn't you make
them do that before was all this for the
comedic hijinks didn't Jarrah build this
then how does detective Mike Lowrey know
how to activate the kill switch so
easily it's necessary for the movie to
have Serleena come back but how does
this thing still exist he paper eyes her
including all her snakes so how does
something come from nothing also as much
as they know about every single species
they uncover and the fact that there was
still a visible remnant here how is it
possible they just left it there to do
it's bad guy is an actually dead cliche
without a single thought I don't think I
have the patience at this point to
detail this piece by piece but they
launched this car in the middle of Times
Square then fly all the way out of Times
Square without turning to fly into Times
Square again then they fly with the
Empire State Building behind you know
what I said I wasn't gonna detail all
this damn it just know the geography in
this chase is a total cluster
what's the navigational stock good to
see Sony being truthful about exactly
how their PlayStation controller works
man when I had to replace so many after
they accidentally got thrown to the
ground really hard no I said listen
bitch if you don't want me to kick your
skinny no diet ass I'm sure that's all
kinds of pissed but it's the reference
to the ever popular zone diet that
really saves it transfer your chairs
then your mother will give you a gameboy
a gameboy has two buttons at a four
direction pad not sure
that's supposed to help with the obvious
playstation controller but at least I
know the movie will be over soon when is
he movie makes it seem like Jeff is just
always hanging out in the New York City
Express tracks the whole idea of Jeff
should have been scrapped due to the
logistical nightmares he causes from
track obstruction to being seen by the
public he makes no sense
boos fun fact
oops teeth was recently voted the number
two cause of breakups in a recent
Reader's Digest survey it was only
beaten by oops my ring is missing
check-offs Jeff where is the light right
here okay Laura Laura no she's her
daughter makes sense I suppose but could
anything about this movie be more
underdeveloped what I'm the light no no
way see now this is the perfect moment
to zap her memory and say you are an
alien princess and in order to save our
planet you need to leave now but no we
need a forced love story in a few more
minutes - let's see ralina return
you know things before they happen I'm a
Libra use orphan when you get sad it
always seems too right did any of this
happen in the movie I guess it did but
telling the future J&K came back to the
worm guy's apartment to find out that
she's been taken away by two-headed
Johnny Knoxville these concepts were
either barely explored or are true Will
Smith in rosario Dawson looks at at each
other for 25 seconds before anyone says
anything
Serleena found a way to control Jeff
while inside his stomach look madam did
she know where to go they flew to the
top of a tall building after that mess
in the subway so what gives why didn't
you tell me would you have let her go
home he just learned about it and
considering that he was just trying to
get Laura on the spaceship a minute ago
the answer is cooking yes well sir
Elena's evaporated again which means
she'll be back for one more fight here
in a minute wait she's not and why
didn't she die the other time she got
wiped out give me your tired plot
devices yearning to be believed must
beyond stupid what about the part you
had to tell the neuralyzed what to
believe what about the part where you
set the time on the device so you don't
erase important memories what about the
part where there is hardly anyone
looking at the Statue of Liberty right
now what about a heads up for the other
MIT agents
what about x-men did it better mother
freedom oh so we're in a locker of an
even bigger world much like the guys in
the train station locker I'm sure this
is an idea that will be explored fully
on men in black 3 coming soon to a
theater ten years well they probably
forgot about this then never mind
ain't nobody don't want my click-click
click-click what have you it's just a
call
[Music]
you ever feel like you're alone in the
universe yeah that's right just about
everybody works in a post office as an
alien how long you been here 48 years
next year they move me up to parcels I'm
lucky and no one can cross a ball or
Bend It Like Beckham
you've lost you insignificant speck
you've wasted 25 years of my time and
for what useful having dog you got me
Bardo Auggie
[Music]
didn't that promise you fireworks